- It's giving Tuesday tomorrow, everyone,
which is one reason why we are very happy
to have our first guest here today.
You may know him best as
an award-winning actor
and musician, but he's also got a podcast
where he talks with
people about giving back
and changing the world for the better.
It's called "Six Degrees
with Kevin Bacon".
You can listen wherever
you get your podcasts.
Everybody, give it up for Kevin Bacon.
(audience yells and claps)
(band music playing)
Oh my gosh, you're in a band.
You get that.
Do you just get up on stage
sometimes and go, huh?
- Yeah, I do oftentimes.
And I have to say, I love this outfit.
- [Kelly] Oh, thank you.
- It's so good.
- [Kelly] Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- Can I say that?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It reminds me of the 1968
Elvis Comeback Special.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Have you ever seen that?
- No, but anytime I remind
someone of the king,
I'm totally cool with that.
- Let me tell you, watch the
1968 Elvis Comeback Special.
- Okay, I should've done a move.
- And he's basically, he's
basically copying your style.
- Yeah, back to the future, there we go.
But you, I just moved here.
So you first moved here awhile
back, but what was it like?
- 1976 I moved here.
- [Kelly] Did you love it?
- I loved it, yeah.
I grew up in Philly, and um.
- [Kelly] That's not far, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, it's not far.
I'd been here a few times
because my sister lived here.
My sister lived on West End Avenue,
so she was very nice to
let me sleep on her couch
for probably, I don't know, four months
until I got my feet on the ground, yeah.
- That's nice.
Yeah, because it's not a cheap city, no.
- No, no, although I can
tell you that in 1976,
my budget for my apartment
was $150 a month.
- So you lived in a closet.
- Right, well.
- [Kelly] Of someone else's.
- Someone else's closet.
Well, what happened was
I had figured it was 150,
I don't know where I got the math on that,
but that's what I had decided.
- Yeah.
- And so I went into this,
I saw an ad in the back
of the "Village Voice", and it said,
artists, actors, musicians, residents.
And I thought, well that sounds good.
It was basically a flop
house, really, I mean.
I don't know, I guess there
were some artists there,
but not a lot.
- Like do you mind living with rats?
- Exactly, yeah, exactly.
But I walked into the rental office,
and the guy said, no, we don't have any
single room apartments, but we
do have a two-room apartment.
So basically it was a
kitchen and another room.
And I said, he said that's
three and a quarter a month,
and I said I can't afford that
and I don't have a roommate.
And he said, what about this guy?
I'm sitting on the couch and
I look, I don't know this guy,
and he goes, you want to live together?
And I was like, yeah, okay.
Yeah, okay, we'll live together.
Yeah, and we lived
together for four years.
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, in fact I just had
lunch with him the other day.
- What?
- And he was a classical pianist.
- You were both musicians,
yeah, that's cool.
- Yeah, he was great,
great, played beautifully.
You know, in the middle of the afternoon,
he worked nights at the Copa Cabana,
and in the middle of the afternoon.
- This is a TV show, what?
- Yeah, yeah, he'd come home,
and he'd be playing Chopin or whatever.
It was really cool.
- That's incredible.
I actually moved out to
LA with some random person
I did not know.
- Really?
- Yeah, she just needed a roommate.
I was like, I'll do it.
And I moved from Texas
to LA with a stranger.
- Wow, and how long did that last?
- Not long, we moved into a place,
and it burnt down.
So yeah, then I slept
in my car for a few days
and then tried out for a
show called "American Idol".
So it all worked out.
(audience cheering)
Yeah, life, yeah.
I feel like everyone in this
industry has some crazy thing
where you've either lived in your car
or on a mattress in
someone's house or yeah,
it's like, yeah, you really
gotta want your dream.
- You do, you gotta have the hunger.
- Yeah, the universe
makes you really want it.
But you played with Billy
Joel in Madison Square Garden.
That is incredible.
- I did, yeah, it was amazing.
- [Kelly] I would love to do that.
(audience clapping)
Were you nervous?
- Oh my God, what, are you kidding me?
Of course, of course I was nervous, yeah.
- I wouldn't have been
nervous about the audience.
I would have been nervous about him.
- Well, yeah, I mean listen,
you know it's one of those
moments where you look at the,
they sent me the set list,
and I looked at the set
list, and I was like,
oh wow, every single one of
the songs on this set list
is like a massive hit.
- Is like a massive hit.
Yeah.
- It was just a weird thing
because I'm a Billy Joel fan,
but I never met Billy.
We didn't know each other.
And he reached out to say did Kira and I
want to come to the show?
And I said, yeah, of
course, and we were like,
wow, that's awesome.
Billy Joel was, we can go
to the show at the Garden.
And then about a week later, it was like,
do you want to come to the
show and also do a song?
I was like, what?
It was literally if I could,
it was like, you know.
- Yeah, and then grab tequila, yeah.
- Grab tequila.
- You're like, wait,
what about this decision?
- I had the tequila
ready for after the show.
- [Kelly] For after.
- Yes.
- That was probably smart,
that was a smart decision.
- Yeah, so it was really fun.
- But you're not just, you
just got honored in Philly.
You got a...
- Yeah, my brother and I.
- You got the walk of
fame, that's so cool.
(audience cheering)
That's amazing.
Leslie Odom Junior was
just here like a week ago.
He got that too.
- [Kevin] That's right.
- [Kelly] Yeah, he's from Philly as well.
- [Kevin] Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's prestigious, yeah.
- Well listen, I mean Philadelphia
has an amazing music tradition.
- [Kelly] Yeah, Pink's from Philly too.
- Yeah, Pink.
- There's a lot of good
people coming out of there.
(audience cheering)
Congratulations.
- John Oates, I mean, and just
the sound of Philadelphia,
all those, you know,
Kenny Gamble, Leon Huff,
all those great song writers.
And it was really cool.
I mean this is a street that, you know,
is only a few blocks
from where I grew up, so.
- Wow, that makes it more special.
- Yeah definitely.
- That's really cool, awesome.
(band music playing)
All right you all.
We are back with Kevin Bacon.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
Kevin actually plays a few instruments
and just learned another,
so let's see that.
- This is called pig
belly, it goes like this.
(hands patting pig)
(audience cheering)
- Like first of all, we
didn't show the beginning,
where you're kind of
rubbing against her hair.
- Yeah.
- That was also nice, the sound.
It was like a little washboard.
Do you usually play on pigs?
- Yeah, he has very, very,
is very bristly, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He sounds great, that
pig, he really does.
- Well speaking of pigs,
something just happened
in Kevin's home state that
had a lot of people worried.
Here are some headlines.
Kevin Bacon, the pig, not the actor,
missing after PA barn escape.
Kevin Bacon remains on
the run in central PA.
It feels like I'm on SNL right now.
An escaped pet pig named Kevin Bacon
is becoming an internet sensation.
I heard you actually
helped find Kevin Bacon.
- Well, I didn't help find Kevin Bacon.
- [Kelly] With a flashlight, and yeah.
- No, I pointed out that he was missing.
- I know, but you have a
lot of followers, so yeah.
- Well I don't know, if I
was helpful, I'm thrilled.
- Yeah, it's a great name
for a pig, it's amazing.
- Yeah, it is.
- I'm mad I never thought of it.
We had a pig, named her Sadie.
We should have named it Kevin Bacon.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- But we have a family
member of Kevin Bacon pig
in our audience.
Everybody meet Chelsea.
What's up, Chelsea?
(audience clapping)
So, you found the pig, right?
- We found the pig, we found the bacon.
- [Kelly] Did you find
out where Kevin Bacon was?
- So.
- Was he in a barn dancing?
- He did wonder close to the
barn, but there was no dancing.
- Okay, disappointment,
all right, all right.
How did the pig get home?
How did you end up figuring it out?
- So, he was on the land for
about two and a half weeks,
and you know, we had shared
on social media about it
because I didn't want the
local hunters to find my pig
and make a mistake.
- Yeah.
- So we put it online,
and then Kevin Bacon human
shared the story about Kevin Bacon pig,
and honestly, it was such.
- How many times do you
think we'll say Kevin Bacon
in this episode?
- A million.
It was really renewed hope when
Kevin Bacon human shared it.
It was getting a little
rough in the trenches,
and you know, the next thing we knew
somebody was suggesting
that I put out donuts
for Kevin Bacon pig.
So I didn't have donuts,
but I got sticky buns
and pet-safe Benadryl.
- Yeah.
I love that you said pet-safe.
You're like, don't attack me, people.
- Yeah, I took a bite out
of it first, it's fine.
- Yeah, and he took a nap.
- Yes, he wondered on in sleepily,
and now he's home forever and safe.
- Aw, that's sweet.
I love, pets are our family.
- Yes, you know what's interesting is that
my wife often uses sticky buns
and Benadryl to lure me in.
- This is, to get you to go to sleep.
I have so many jokes that
aren't daytime right now,
it's funny.